when you think of leonardo da vinci you
probably think of the mona lisa
leonardo da vinci is one of the most
famous artists in the world
but he is much more than that indeed he
never thought of himself as an artist
when he sent a letter to the ruler of
milan describing his strengths when he
was looking for work
he listed 10 different skills and almost
as an afterthought he mentioned he could
also
paint the reason his artworks are so
realistic and detailed
is that he invested much of his time in
the study of science
da vinci was born in a village near
vinci just outside florence in 1452
the illegitimate son of a farmer's
daughter and a prominent lawyer
although he didn't receive any formal
education his artistic ability was clear
from a very early age
when he was 15 he studied under the
acclaimed artist andrea del verrocchio
in florence
when da vinci helped verauchio paint an
angel in the baptism of christ
the story goes that his version was so
much better than his masters
that varrocchio vowed never to pick up a
paintbrush again
da vinci was a notoriously slow painter
and many of his works were never
finished
only about two dozen survive a drop in
the bucket compared to other artists van
gogh
left more than 2 000 works da vinci
wasn't just interested in how the human
body or nature looked on a canvas
he wanted to know why they appeared as
they did he was able to give the mona
lisa that mysterious look on her face
because he studied all the muscles
involved in smiling
if you wanted to learn about the human
anatomy in the 1500s there was no easy
way to do so
no medical textbooks and of course no
way to google search and image
so he studied the only way he could by
examining corpses
hospitals were keen to support his
artistic research and gave him access to
cadavers
he dissected over 30 bodies in his
lifetime and filled thousands of pages
with notes and detailed drawings
if you're having trouble reading this
it's because da vinci had a habit of
writing backward
he also liked to go from right to left
he was left-handed so some have
speculated this would have stopped his
ink from smudging
as a result his writing can only be read
normally in a mirror
he probably wouldn't have done this if
he had any intention of publishing his
notes
his depictions of the body are beautiful
and for the most part
accurate so accurate that professors can
actually use his drawings to teach
anatomy
one of his most famous works that
perfectly illustrates the fusion of art
and science
is the vitruvian man which depicts the
proportions of the human body according
to vitruvius a roman architect
the man's outstretched arms are equal to
his height which is true for most people
he was particularly obsessed with the
heart which he described as a wonderful
instrument invented by the supreme
master
many of his medical conclusions about
the heart have turned out to be
stunningly accurate
he was the first to describe the heart
as a muscle that it has four chambers
and that the arterial valves opened and
closed to let blood flow around the
organ
he was also the first to recognize
coronary artery disease
around 1506 he witnessed a 100 year old
man die suddenly
he dissected his heart and discovered
that his arteries had narrowed
he deduced this was what killed him he
was far ahead of his time
coronary artery disease wouldn't be
described by a physician until more than
150 years later
it's a mystery why he never published
any of his work his notes were not
discovered until the late 18th century
more than 250 years after his death
had they been known during his lifetime
they could have had a profound effect on
the understanding of the human body
and perhaps helped physicians find ways
to heal certain ailments in the same way
that he studied the body to improve his
paintings and then became obsessed with
anatomy
he studied plants to improve his art and
then became obsessed with botany
he drew most of his delicate works with
red chalk his sketches of plants were so
accurate they could have been considered
scientific studies
in the study of the star of bethlehem
the swirls of leaves are similar to the
movement of water
another one of his obsessions da vinci
dedicated a lot of time trying to
understand the flow of water
most of his 72-page scientific diary
called the codex luster
is dedicated to the study of the motion
of water in seas rivers and canals
bill gates bought it for nearly 31
million making it the most expensive
book
ever sold da vinci also invented the
lock that almost any canal or waterway
you visit uses to this day
the lock was mitered as in two 45-degree
angles meet each other at a point
his contribution to engineering extended
from the water to the skies
da vinci sketched out this flying
machine that he called the aerial screw
while he was employed as a military
engineer by the duke of milan in the
1490s
the device was meant to be powered by
four men who would push the four wooden
shafts in a circular motion
da vinci believed this would generate
enough force to lift it off the ground
had he actually attempted to create a
real-life model it would have been too
heavy to lift
but the basic principles of liftoff
provided the earliest foundation for
modern helicopters he also made sketches
of a parachute speculating that if a
person had a tent made from linen that
matched their proportions
they would be able to jump from any
height without being injured once again
he didn't make a real-life model
but a british skydiver did use da
vinci's idea 500 years later
in 2000 and it worked in practice
davinci clearly had confidence in his
own designs and had done some
mathematical equations
he applied math to his paintings the
last supper one of the most recognizable
works in the world
is a prime example of the use of the
mathematical principle of perspective
jesus is sharing a final meal with his
12 disciples before his crucifixion
all the lines in the painting converge
in one place known as the vanishing
point so that the focus is on jesus
this was done to emphasize the
importance of christ and he wasn't
afraid to try new things visually
the traditional florentine way of
painting was to outline an image giving
it a very crisp
appearance instead he perfected a new
technique
fumato which means vanished or
evaporated in italian
it gets rid of hard edges by blending
everything without lines or borders
the mona lisa is a classic example of
the use of sfu mato particularly in the
shading around the eyes
he also began to experiment with new
materials for painting
renaissance period artists were moving
away from egg tempera paint which was
pigments mixed with egg yolk and water
to oil paints which allowed for more
vivid colors and greater contrasts
however oil paints were complicated to
make and the quality fluctuated greatly
so da vinci put on his chemistry hat and
cooked his own pigments in linseed oil
at a low temperature and added about
five percent of beeswax
which prevented the paint from darkening
on the canvas
da vinci's art was a confluence of
biology chemistry engineering
mathematics and physics
he employed all these skills when
france's king francis the first
appointed him
as the first painter engineer and
architect of the king when he was
already in his sixties
his final work was not a painting but a
party he threw in the summer of 1518
at his residence at the chateau de
claude lucer the king's summer castle in
central france to thank him for his
generosity
there was a spectacle at the party where
players dressed up as planets
surrounded by the sun and the moon da
vinci was the first to explain
why you can see light between the two
points of a crescent moon
he figured out it was due to sunlight
hitting the earth and reflecting onto
the moon
called earth shine this was an
outlandish theory at the time
most people didn't even know that earth
orbited the sun he was once again
far far ahead of his time when da vinci
passed away at the chateau
on the 2nd of may in 1519 he left behind
thousands of pages of notes and drawings
for future generations
he may be best known for his art but
clearly he was a jack of all trades and
the master of them all if you like to
master stem subjects just like da vinci
brilliant can help and it's free to sign
up my sponsor brilliant is a website and
app that helps you brush up on your math
science and computer science skills take
this lesson on the insertion sort
algorithm for example
if you've never done computer science
before this can seem like pretty heady
stuff
but on brilliant there's no coding
syntax needed you just move around
blocks of code
and get immediate feedback on your
results so you can develop a deep
understanding of how this algorithm
works
there are no tests it's for all skill
levels and if you're feeling stuck on a
problem you can read the explanations to
find out more
all you have to do to get started is
pick a course and jump right in
there's something for everyone from
exercising your critical thinking skills
through logic courses
to learning about cryptocurrency it's
free to sign up for brilliant
and the first 200 people who use my link
will get 20
off the premium subscription which gives
you unlimited access to all the courses
the link is in my description
for newsthink i'm cindy palm